6 38 right now so if you've been worth
thinking about
a new career but you don't have a lot of
free time college of southern nevada is
trying to make classes and higher
education more accessible
there's a new program offering classes
just on the weekends
hector mejia live from csn's western
high tech center with some details on
that hector good morning
just on the weekends hey there john good
morning and csn says it came up with
this in response to the pandemic to
train more people
and help them enter the workforce and
they're offering classes in education
healthcare iit welding and air
conditioning technology which is
the reason why we're in this room and
joining us live we have crystal to
explain
all right so if a student is working on
this piece uh
at this learning station what are some
of the steps they'll go through as they
try to
figure out what's wrong with it
absolutely so basically any student can
go up to this unit and they can check
the charge they can check the
the electrical components they can check
out the high voltage low voltage and
they can make sure that the system is
running properly at optimum levels
and basically these students can install
and replace the motors and the
compressors in this unit
and so shows right now uh you know some
of the steps yeah
so basically we'll go ahead and turn
that puppy on and at this point
we have now turned on the enemy now we
can hear it so it's working we can hear
it it's wonderful
it's not something wrong with it there
is nothing wrong with that right now it
is
already fixed and the student got an a
it is wonderful
[Music]
tell us about the field and how in
demand it is right now and
how long could it take for someone to uh
be able to enter the workforce already
yes so the students can actually enroll
now
check check it out we got the weekend
calls is happening we got the
installation classes happening the
installation is a big
high demand because older units are
going out
they are being phased out we need new
installers and there's an installation
class and i would
i would encourage everyone to check that
out crystal time is running out right
you're telling me
it's the last week students are able to
enroll late because classes already
start this weekend
yes it's already thursday it's already
thursday check it out sign up because we
got
we also got dynamic classes that start a
little later but please check it out
before they fill
up and lastly before we go the classes
are you can get your certificate uh
and as quickly as a weekend depending on
your needs or even just an entire year
right
absolutely so you can check out the
entry level air conditioning technician
certificates and
we got them going on for for dynamic
courses for
you all right crystal there you go we're
posting all of the details on our
website eightnewsnow.com
for now reporting live hector mejia back
to you guys